at what point are you guys like at this  point politics what role does politics  play in your life at 18 years ago going  into boot camp about all Republicans was  racist I thought oh white people's  racist yeah  um I was raised to be a Democrat  my mom always uh taught us to see look  Democrats are for blacks Republicans or  for whites yeah she taught me that from  as young as I can remember like five six  seven years old I remember was watching  the debate and then she always  up and down she couldn't stand a  republican yeah what was the reasoning  because she linked Republicans to racism  as I can she was very naive when it came  to politics mom had no idea that Jim  Crow was about Democrats she had no idea  that the KKK was started by the  Democrats she had no idea my mom was a  good woman but she ain't no [ __ ] about  polish